el presidente joe biden luego de esta
reunión de cerca de tres horas que tuvo
con el presidente putin dentro de todo
eso le preguntaron ya hacia el final de
esta conferencia de prensa porque se
habían demorado solamente hubo cerca de
tres horas cuando se esperaba que fueran
cuatro o cinco horas el presidente baile
dijo sencillamente que al cabo de un
momento se dieron cuenta que ya íbamos
habían ha tocado todos los temas que se
tenían previstos porque de hecho tanto
es serguéi lávrov quien es el ministro
de relaciones internacionales de ave
rusa de rusia y su homólogo anthony
blinken pues ya habían preparado de
antemano esta reunión así que esto
permitió que se avanzara de pronto una
manera mucho más rápida de la esperada
dentro de lo que usted debe notar pues
si lo de los ciberataques digamos que
hay
byd empecé hizo énfasis en que hay un
acuerdo en que van a enviar se expertos
a ambos países para determinar dónde se
originan estos ciberataques esto del
ransomware y el de hecho pues en lo que
le dijo a putin es que le dio una lista
de 16 digamos entidades o 10 y 16
infraestructuras críticas que no pueden
ser víctima de este tipo
es ciberataques así que él es una lista
normalmente 16 también se mostró en
digamos se dio a entender que se fue muy
claro cuando se habló de los derechos
humanos de que esto es lo que él está
haciendo en realidad es defender los
valores de su país y que él no puede
presentarse como presidente de eeuu así
no defiende ciertos valores y ciertos
derechos frente a un país como rusia así
que él dijo que las consecuencias serían
devastadoras para rusia en caso de que
alexéi navalni el líder opositor quien
está encarcelado pues muriera en prisión
pero vayan dijo que se trató de una
buena discusión que fue una discusión
positiva en la que se pudo sobre todo
adelantar más que todo en cuanto a esto
de las armas nucleares poder profundizar
aún más en este tratado start ese es un
paso hacia adelante y justamente entre
entre las dos conferencias justamente
antes hubo un comunicado conjunto
entregado por moscú en él
explicaban que ambos países se
comprometían en que no hubiera un
conflicto nuclear porque sabían que es
necesaria esa estabilidad estratégica
ese ese digamos esa expresión que
utilizó no solamente a vladimir putin
sino que retomó también al presidente
vayan hablando de la importancia pues de
esta estabilidad que es importante no
solamente que haya equilibrio entre
estas dos grandes potencias nucleares
sino que en realidad las consecuencias
son también para el mundo entero de que
pueda pues haber paz habló rápidamente
el presidente vaivén de temas como por
ejemplo afganistán siria libia dijo que
de todas maneras pues se había quedado
claro que a rusia pues podría bien estar
allí para para ayudar pero no aún ahondó
en ese tema y dijo como usted viene lo
recalcó que la idea aquí no es que haya
un regreso a ningún tipo de guerra fría
que el mundo no vuelva a este tipo de
mundo partido digamos en dos y por eso
es importante precisamente estas
reuniones de verse de estar juntos
que haya algún tipo de diversión que
haga que haya sobre todo malos
entendidos por último le decían se había
renovado retomado confianza entre los
dos países el presidente badén dijo que
en este caso no significaba o no se
trataba de confianza sino simplemente de
verificación y de actuar esas fueron las
palabras a grosso modo de todo lo que
dijo el joe biden a lo largo de este
discurso que un poquito más corto que el
del presidente putin quien ya se fue de
aquí de la vila la granja en ginebra